-You guys, last night
was the Christmas tree lighting
in Rockefeller Center.
Did you see that?
It was beautiful.
And this year's tree
has over 50,000 lights,
which explains why NBC
just told me
I can't use a hair dryer
for the next month.
I was wondering why.
But last night was also
the Christmas tree lighting
at the White House.
And President Trump
gave a speech,
but right at the start,
he had some trouble saying
the word "Christmas."
Listen to this.
[ Applause ]
-Merry Chrissus, Muh--
Everybody.
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
"M-Merry -- Uh --
[ Speaking gibberish ]
It's like they're playing him
in reverse.
It's like, "Paul is dead."
He's like -- Can we play it
again one more time, Dave?
-Merry Chrissus, Muh--
Everybody.
-Yeah.
Yeah. He sounds like your uncle
after his third eggnog.
He's like, "Uh, Christmas,
and you're the one that said --"
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like, "Forget it.
Let's go back to
'happy holidays.'
That's much easier."
[ Cheers and applause ]
But it's been a busy 24 hours
for the President.
Last night, Trump flipped on
the Christmas tree lights,
and today Michael Cohen
flipped on Trump.
[ Laughter ]
It's big news. Cohen was
one of Trump's closest allies,
and now he's working
with Mueller.
I'm not saying Trump's
running out of friends,
but he today he asked
Rosie O'Donnell if she
wanted to get lunch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What? No.
And Cohen says
he's cooperating with Mueller
'cause he wants to put
family and country first.
Trump replied, "I totally agree.
Wait. You're talking
about my family, right?"
[ Applause ]
This morning, Trump talked
to reporters about Cohen,
and when he referenced a
document that Cohen once signed,
he really made
to sure to act out
what a piece of paper
looks like. Watch this.
-He talks about a letter
that he signed.
I don't even remember it.
And it specifically talks
about this deal.
And I think January,
he was a written statement.
[ Laughter ]
Reporters are like,
"Uh, TV show, uh, three words.
Uh, no. Two words? Two words?"
"Cohen signed --
He signed the paper.
He put a stamp on it,
and he put it in the mail.
He mailed it.
[ Laughter ]
And then he told everybody..."
No.
[ Laughter ]
While he called on reporters,
Trump had an interesting way
of using his finger to point
at who he wanted to speak next.
Watch this.
[ Reporters shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
[ Reporters shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
-It's like he's trying
to cast a spell on reporters.
Like, "Fake Newsicus!
[ Laughter ]
Fake Newsicus.
Really Fake Newsicus."
It's like everybody's dad using
an iPad for the first time.
He's like, "All right.
Now I just touch it right there.
I'm going to select it.
Here we go."
This is very interesting.
I saw that Starbucks is going to
start blocking adult websites
from their Wi-Fi networks.
[ Audience booing ]
[ Laughter ]
They said there's a time and a
place for that type of behavior,
and it's all day
at Dunkin' Donuts.
I mean, that's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, health officials
just announced that it is time
to throw away your
Thanksgiving leftovers
because they are not
safe to eat.
So don't even try it. No.
But...
as for me...
♪♪ I'm holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
I'm holding out for
if I eat it, I get E. coli
if I eat it, I will die
If I enjoy it,
I'm a happy guy
Will I kill bacteria
if it's fried?
-♪♪ Two, three, four ♪♪
-♪♪ I'm holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪ I'm holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-Come on! Everybody!
-♪♪ Holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ I'm holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ I'm holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ I'm holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ I'm holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ I'm holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ I'm holding out
for one more ♪♪
♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show tonight!
Give it up for The Roots!
-♪♪ Holding out
for one more, yeah ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Holding out for
one more turkey sandwich ♪♪
-♪♪ Turkey sandwich ♪♪